who was that guy that brother was the
best damn soldier had ever lived
I'm gonna start with this film because
basically I loved how you began it the
same way you began black clansmen and
had the film sort of bookends with
historical footage and I was wondering
what were your choices on what footage
you wanted to use with that is that
something already in the script and like
how you chose those particular words
from those particular men's is sort of I
think heightened what the film was
trying to say its historical footage you
know so I have a great researcher her
name is Judy Ailey been working with me
for many many years and she finds
everything and so we make the choice in
the editing room what we're gonna use
but to give you a better answer I knew I
wanted to have as you use the word
bookends I wanted the two individuals in
the prologue and epilogue be two people
who are vocal about early when it wasn't
popular about the Vietnam War the more
how immoral that war was Muhammad Ali
very famous statement no viacom ever
call me [ __ ] he's great he sacrificed
lost the prime his prime years as a
boxing stripped of his Heavyweight
Champion and then the epilogue with dr.
Martin Luther King who also paid a price
I think that's why I got assassinated he
wasn't talking about like people you
know getting it he'd count his rifle you
know he's talking about the power
structure he's talking about war war is
an economy Wars a business Dow Chemical
Oh napalm Agent Orange he was messing
with the money yeah plus I think that
LBJ was feeling different about him
he thought he had a el ally with distill
Rights Act of 1964 but we saw dr. King
step out and say the world though this
Vietnam war is immoral changed
everything it changed everything
no it's amazing in a lot of ways
Muhammad Ali was the Colin Kaepernick of
that era and he had the same penalty
it's so funny how history repeats itself
bringing it back to the film though I
want to talk about Kim Coleman's your
longtime casting director and I love her
I've gotten to chat with her a couple
times I did one of the few interviews
she ever allows anyone to do but she is
so great at finding young talent I mean
you know she casts you know Anthony and
she hate me and she cast Tiana and like
chiraq but this one you guys got
Jonathan did you know Jonathan majors
before did she bring him into you how
did she bring him and I knew I heard of
him but Kim she was like you got to see
his guys work I said all right because
you know Kim's not gonna steer me wrong
I was gonna make him read you know you
know just just you know sit down and you
know vibe but Kim was not wrong she had
me rolling me so far so uh Thank You Kim
Coleman riparian hey don't you come back
inside
don't worry I would start with you but I
want to ask both of you why do you think
the Vietnam War is something that like
cinematically we want to revisit like
why does it always seem so I would say
topical and why is it I guess something
that people like to look back on from a
movie standpoint because I think it's
unfinished business and I think it's
unfinished business from the standpoint
when I say unfinished yes that the
conflict came to an end but psychically
it's unfinished business because it goes
against the American creed of we are the
ship when we take care of something we
take care of it and it goes expressly
against that Creed because they did not
get taken care of
in fact the exact opposite so I think
that it is a bone that sticks in the
craw of the culture in addition to which
there is the unfinished business of how
human beings were mistreated the
thousands and thousands of young men who
were drafted against their will the
thousands and thousands of young men who
came back and were mistreated the
thousands of young men that the country
turned its back on at the time all of
that as far as I can see constitute
unfinished business things that need to
be redressed that need to be redressed
and
and if not made right they need to be
redressed and re-examined so I think
that maybe that may be part of the
reason for the continued fascination
with this this this conflict which has
created a conflict inside the culture
this may be controversial but America
does not like to lose that's right
nor does she like to be stained I like
in the Vietnam War and the Canon of
films to that of Antebellum and slave
narratives that flowed in a
be told by the same demographic and
usually told the same amount of tone and
there is a very clear in my opinion
agenda which is to cover up or to ratify
something that is actually permanent
yeah so that's all I think we keep going
back to Italy and there's a voyeuristic
quality to it because nobody knows what
actually happened what we do know is
that slavery was wrong right it was
[ __ ] up you can't change it in the
Vietnam War we had no business being
that period we know that right
these things are wrong inherently
morally wrong economically that's where
it gets hairy but that's we were wrong
in that right and so we you know it's
just you go back to your vomit no it's a
very good put is so well yeah similar
our aunt was similar yeah
I'm sorry and I will not take from your
time but it's it's it comes from the
same I don't know ethos I don't know I'm
not sure if that's the word this
continuing fascination with Marilyn
Monroe why is there this confessor
nation with Marilyn Monroe Dorothy
Dandridge doesn't get the same kind of
and they were both tragic American
stories but somehow there is this
continuing to go back to examine it and
re-examine re-examine it some more
movies and we got one movie on TV for
Dorothy Dandridge that says everything I
just want to make sure I get this in
before I have to get out of here both of
you are working with spike in a totally
different way Delroy you have decades of
history with Spike both as a
collaborator and then also just as a
friend and then Jonathan this is the
first film you didn't done with him and
I'm just wondering how is that different
because Jonathan stepping on that set
spike we're
with the same people over and over and
over again so there's a like a complete
family aspect and then Delroy was like
for you coming back after a certain
period of time and and so I'll just let
you both take one of each
good job yes sir I mean coming in it's
like you know I played sports coming
coming up you know and it's like you get
put on a select team you know you work
in a certain district you play for a
certain area right and then if you're
lucky you could put on certain select
team and that's the LED team has one
coach and that Coach is selected because
of what he or she is capable of doing
what they've done so being you know
being picked to be on this team and to
work with this coach and to be thrown
the ball from these ball players you
know was a huge the huge shift you know
was a huge like okay I'm here now and
what spike did and I think what
permeated throughout the cast is that
everyone was there for a reason and then
I felt I I mean look I know Darrell endo
is you don't say I know who he is
I'd know the thermography right but he
was on the team and that was the great
equalizer we were all on set if you're
on that you were here to play ball
that's right and the coach puts you here
so that's right place up and let's go
that belly if the coach put you here
you're supposed to be here right let's
put you here you know because if you
weren't supposed to be here the coach
would not put you there all day long
coming back felt like after 20 plus
years just it felt as appropriate and
right as it ever did I auditioned for
Malcolm X and he selected me he put me
on the team that's the last time I've
auditioned for Spike Lee or maybe
anything but certainly for Spike Lee
he offered me cook okay making my point
home come on now I'm making up
when bra come on now he no my point is
he selected me he put me on the taming
and Crooklyn he put me on the team in
cloppers he didn't say ok you have to
pass this test to get on the team he
said I want you on the team and after
all these years he's not coming back to
me after all these years and saying I
want you on the team
so affirmation after affirmation after
affirmation what more could I ask for as
an actor the this is why one became an
actor to have these kinds of
extraordinary relationships with one's
fellow workers I get I got I got asked
to be on the team so Jonathan majors
that was my point bro come on now
who was that guy that brother was the
best damn soldier had ever lived I
wanted to start with well basically I've
been asking everyone this because it
seems that although this is maybe one of
the first movies of this time period
that centers on all black characters the
Vietnam War is something that keeps
getting revisited in movies and
television and I was wondering if each
of you could maybe tell me why you think
it's something that folks keep going
back to and Clark I'll start with you
and then Norman and I think they keep
going back to it because it was such a
controversial it came up at such a
controversial time in America's history
the civil rights movement was going on
at the same time as we were going into
Vietnam and that may have been one of
the reasons why dr. King was brought to
an end because his focus shifted from
the civil rights movement to something
that America was dealing with the other
thing is that this is the first time
that you're seeing the stories of the
black experience in Vietnam which since
Vietnam was never focused on yeah so
again a very a very important reason for
it voice for it to be I think that's
your question was that right no that's
perfect thank you and Norman if you had
anything oh just to add on top of that
and actually I got a history lesson
while we've been doing a lot of these
interviews we were at that time 11% of
the population of the United States but
yet 33 percent of the population of the
army so it was interesting how there was
so many blacks being sent over to fight
for this war and yet we were still
fighting for our rights at home and it
was it's yeah yeah you know we keep
going back to it I don't think so
because I don't think we've ever told
this story this you know that we've
never we've never gone to it even in the
documentaries that I that I watched and
I watched about three different sets we
never went to the black experience in
Vietnam even though we were it was a
disproportionate amount of African
Americans who were there that's a huge
chunk to leave out so
I like the fact that we can finally get
that out there and we can show the
people that we were represented there
and a lot of people doubted there and it
was it was interesting to just to add
onto that we had a lesson while we were
over there learning about that culture
we there were films that we saw
videotapes that we are DVDs that we saw
about the black culture and learning how
to recognize each other by doing the
Deaf and there were certain ways to
recognize different people from
different platoons and it became such a
thing that a lot of the white superiors
would put people in jail for doing that
it's interesting you guys have all
worked with spike in some way he's such
a huge icon in film and everybody I
think is intrigued by his filmmaking
what would folks be surprised is
something that is essential to working
with Spike Lee on set that maybe they
wouldn't think about from either the way
that he directs or the atmosphere he
puts forth I gotta think about what I
have to say make sure I keep working
with Spike you know know it's when we
look at Spike Lee's films we think that
you know I mean and he does have this
incredible vision as to what he wants
but I think a lot of people don't give
him credit for the flexibility that he
has that flexibility that he allows
actors to work within that mold so so
spike is gonna get his shot but he's
also gonna let you get your shot and you
you have the ability to work within that
and that's kind of liberating for an
actor that's kind of freeing for for an
actor it's not as rigid as as it
sometimes has a tendency to look I mean
the shot is going to be there and
usually the shot is brilliant but you do
have a little bit of freedom and I think
that's very important and I think that's
where you get the camaraderie and the
believability in his film
because you as an actor you're allowed
to do that just to piggyback on top of
that yeah he knows what he wants when he
wants it he has a structure that he
wants but yet within that sometimes
he'll see something different because
there's gonna be a different energy that
that we didn't have like in the
rehearsal process and then while we're
in the scene all of a sudden oh say that
line or how would you say that there's a
couple of times he asked Isaiah myself
like okay don't say those lines but what
would you say in this moment and so it
was kind of like like Isaiah was saying
it was freeing and liberating and
exciting but yet you knew you were in
this structure and you you felt safe in
this in the start because after a while
you start doing it without him telling
you just you have that freedom and you
know that you can just kind of let
yourself go I mean that's the beauty and
magic starts to happen in those films
with Anna Clark real quick before they
kick me out of here is that spike in it
okay that's okay I'm sorry Clark I
wanted to get you to answer the question
but both of you guys were great so he
loves the party that's what I was gonna
say he loves the party Hey
[Music]
you